[موسيقى]
مصير مستقبل الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب قاب قوسين او ادنى اما من
نهايه الماساويه او نقله النوعيه في حياته
السياسيه بعد ان خرج ترامب من الانتخابات
النصفيه نوفمبر الماضي بجراح لم تندمل
بخساره عدد من المرشحين الجمهوريين الذين
دعمهم يطلق حملته الرئاسيه للعام 24 بمخوف
من تكرار ذات السيناريو المخيبي لامال
مناصره ترامب معركه ترامب السياسيه تبدا
من ولايه مهاجر حيث يختبر الرئيس الامريكي
السابق قوته كمرشحين في خطاب امام مئات
القاده الجمهوريين
ليتوجهها بعدها لولايه سوف كارولينا وهي
التي ساعدت في تمهيد طريقه ليصبح مرشح
الحزب الجمهوريه في عام 2016 لكنها خذلته
عام 2020 حين ترشح للرئاسه احد اهم اعمده
ذلك التاييد هو السنه والجمهوري
الانستغرام الى جانب الحاكم الجمهوريه
هنريمك ماستر والنا جمهوري المنتخب حديثا
راس الفراي لكن في الوقت نفسه ستغيب اسماء
العديد من الجمهوريين البارزين احدهم هو
المدعي العام للولايه الين والسن وهو مع
اسماء جمهوريه اخرى ترغب في البقاء على
الحياد بعيدا عن الدراما السياسيه والجدل
الذي يلاحق ترامب شبكه سين انا الامريكيه
ترى بان الاحداث المتسارعه على الساحه
السياسيه وظهوره وثائق سريه حكوميه في
منزل بايدا وكذلك في منزل النائب السابق
لترامب مايك برنس قد توفراني فرصه جديده
لاحياء حظوظ ترامب الرئاسيه فيما يقول
موقعه هل ان الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2024
لن تكون مجرده تصويت على من يرغب الجمهور
بان يكون رئيسا للولايات المتحده بل
سيتحول لتصويت حول من يريد الجمهور سجنه
اهو الرئيس الحالي
ام الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب حمزه
العربيه